well Ben Shapiro is here live in
uncensor well that's quite an intro
we've given you and I appreciate it you
better live up to it well I mean I look
at that old tape and suddenly I hit
puberty right we both look so young oh
my God uh I mean that was what that's
probably over 10 10 years ago right 10
years ago and it was interesting because
I was at the time you know getting very
angry about a series of mass shootings
in America with a British sensibility
and saying you know obviously my country
we don't really have any guns and I was
you know hectoring and lecturing I guess
Americans about their gun laws and it
went down as badly as that phrase would
suggest particularly with with you but
what was interesting was when you came
on I thought who's this snotty little
kid who's gonna start trying to take me
on and then it rapidly became clear to
me you were a hell of a lot smarter than
you appear
um so uh we've moved on from then anyway
we've had our kiss and makeup interview
after that but I I think what was really
interesting to me 2016. so seven years
ago now you tweeted a tweet this is your
pinned tweet to this date simply say
said facts don't care about your
feelings and if any phrase I think
perfectly epitomizes this woke era that
we have somehow stumbled into it's fat
because the woke Brigade put feelings
before facts
how do we get there well I mean and
culturally speaking I think that what
happened is that the value of subjective
authenticity became the core to pretty
much everybody so the the idea of
individualism was taken to its logical
extreme which was I'm so important and
everything I feel is so important that I
can ignore the rest of reality and in
fact reality is an imposition on me
institutions rules rules the rules of
the road all that sort of stuff it's an
imposition on who I truly am and in
order for me to be actually free I have
to speak my truth now you know as I've
said and you've said there's no such
thing as my truth right there's your
opinion and then there's the truth but
as soon as you start speaking in terms
of my truth as soon as you start saying
well there's how I feel about the world
and how I feel about the world is the
core of me what that also does it means
that other people are aggressing on you
when they disagree with you because
obviously assured reality means that we
can disagree about things out here but
you know we sort of as human beings are
intact but the moment that you start to
identify your truth with the truth then
anybody attacking your truth is
attacking you as a human being and I
think that that's where we've gone is is
this movement away from we're having a
political debate but again we can go out
and have a drink afterward because we we
are not the political debate the
political debate's a different thing two
my politics are who I am or my feelings
about who I am or my feelings about the
world that's the thing that matters more
than anything else and what's his
jewelry I mean I remember this we're
going to come to them later sadly but
Megan and Harry but they went on Oprah
Winfrey and she started talking
constantly about my truth and Oprah was
endorsing your truth and everything I
was like you I'm living in a sort of mad
world where
truth is no longer factual it's just
whatever you're feeling in any given
moment it seems such a perverse thing
for a Democratic Society that you move
away from fact based from science
whatever it may be to just feelings
dominating a culture and if you defy
those feelings you are instantly branded
the enemy and you must be destroyed well
there's no conversation to be had right
I can't have a conversation about your
feelings you're feeling your feelings
there's no way for me to dissuade you
from you can't deny my feeling correct I
can't say I can deny the facts that you
bring to the table but the problem is
once that becomes irrelevant then we're
just at an impasse there's no more
conversation to be had how big a problem
is it that at the same time
simultaneously I think you've had the
rise of very populist leaders like
Donald Trump Boris Johnson in the UK and
others who play pretty fast and loose
with the truth that you have people who
say well hang on you talk about the
sanctity of truth but you've got these
political leaders U.S presidents British
prime ministers where they don't seem to
care about matures they just bumble
through with whatever suits them from
day to day how dangerous is that to the
whole shebang I mean I think that that
is dangerous but it's dangerous in a
different way and it's also dangerous in
a more consistent and I would say
historically uh precedented way I mean
the fact is the politicians have always
fibbed to us I mean there's nothing new
about politicians saying things that are
not true from from LBJ to to George W
bush to to Donald Trump and Barack Obama
I mean like literally every politician
Joe Biden yeah right you see you see
this all the time so the idea of a
politician not telling the truth or
shading the truth in particular ways
that that's not what's new I think
what's new is where people are presented
with data and their immediate response
isn't let me bring you some data that
robots that data but I don't even have
to look at your data because your
motivation is bad right this philosophy
how dangerous is it though that we've
also become incredibly tribal I think
more than I can ever remember in modern
history actually you know when I read
your Twitter feed I think you're always
prepared to call out your own side if
you genuinely feel there's been some
egregious wrongdoing that they've done
or a terrible mistake or whatever but
the number of people prepared to do that
now on social media in particular is
minuscule most people Park themselves
into their tribe whatever that tribe may
be and there is no moving them there's
no deviation even if the facts change
and again it plays into well if your
feelings are the facts then if you feel
that fact is wrong well that's enough
right but the tribalism that I think has
has cropped up is rooted in a philosophy
called the motivism which is the idea
that everybody's actual viewpoints are
not driven by their view of the facts
it's driven by their internal emotions
what that allows me to do on the on the
converse is attribute malicious intent
to people that I'm arguing with and it
means that I get to ignore all of their
facts the reason that that I'm
disagreeing with you is because I'm good
and you're a bad person and what that
means is that people on my own side for
example they might be upset with me for
talking with people on the other side of
the aisle because why would you talk to
somebody who's a nasty person who has
bad motivations and the same thing on on
people on the other side talking to me
I've was having a conversation one time
with a very very large left-wing
podcaster this is probably 2018 and I
said you know we should really do like a
crossover podcast for the midterm
elections and we'll do huge business and
my side will be totally fine with it
it'll be great and he said your site
will be fine with him my side will kill
me right and that that's probably that's
the way it's got on Bill Maher said to
me you know that comedy used to be
rooted really in right wing extremism
being comedic and that was the that was
where liberal Comics like him could get
their material now he said it's mainly
to the left it's the woke area of
politics that gives him the most comedic
material and he can't believe it as a
liberal himself he feels just really
frustrated that they don't understand
how ridiculous and laughable their
positions on things have become well
it's it's driving a bunch of people who
consider themselves Center or sensor
left into the arms of people who are
more conservative actually I've made the
point before that I think the future of
the West May ride not on people who
agree with me most of the time you know
conservatives traditionalists I think
the future of the rest West might ride
on people who consider themselves kind
of traditional liberals who may agree
with some of the left's prescriptions
economically but who disagree with the
way they want to get there which is very
often by silencing debate using
censorship shutting things down so the
question is going to be are they willing
to put off Utopia for a while in order
to engage in the debate myself I've
always thought myself not really is a
political idea look right I I think I'm
pretty Centrist and call out everybody
really I'm more I see myself as a
journalist fundamentally and don't think
that being partisan helps that
particular profession very much as we've
seen from those who've as she drifted
down into being partisan as journalists
it doesn't work you become an activist
but someone said the other day you know
are you a conservative I said well I'd
never identified as a conservative but
the F the father lunatic that the left
woke go the more the pendulum swings and
eventually we all get sucked into
thinking well okay actually my
comparison to this I probably am getting
a bit conservative because I think
they're lunatics I think what's
happening right now and it's happening
in a bunch of countries is people are
just craving any sense of normality and
Common Sense and no one is providing it
to them right no one is providing to
them they're taking a slap at the people
who are responsible for the status quo
as licensed to now do whatever they want
and so you're seeing the pendulum
swinging wildly side to side because if
you're a political leader you're trying
to harness the passions of the moment to
get done the thing that you really
really want to get done when in reality
the population just wants things to kind
of just stop just like roll us alone and
stop right I totally agree and I think I
think that's the majority of people
right I mean today Rolling Stone uh
published an opinion piece on why cancel
culture is good for democracy and I read
this piece and it was so completely
deluded because of course cancel culture
is the antithesis of a democracy it's
actually the antithesis of liberalism
you can't pretend to be liberal with
what that actually was intended to mean
and support cancel culture I think I
think the left uses cancel culture in a
very different way than most of us use
cancer culture when we talk about cancer
culture typically what we mean is you
say something that they don't like on
the air and they decide to secondarily
boycott your advertisers or they go to
your bosses and call for you to be fired
right and that's what we mean by cancer
culture what they mean is well we're
allowed to disapprove of you well sure
you're allowed to disapprove turn the
channel right you don't have to
subscribe to either why you don't have
to watch your show right but what they
do with that instead is they attempt to
get you kicked off the air not by Dent
of lack of ratings or something but just
because they're so angry that they're
going to go yell at people and bother
them until you get kicked off the air
that's that's what cancel culture really
is I interviewed Congressman George
Santos uh this week who even by the
Staffing politicians I mean it was quite
startling I'll just play the clip where
he admits to being a terrible liar
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure
well I've been a terrible liar on those
subjects
I mean this guy's a serving member of
the United States Congress right he's
one of the most powerful politicians in
the country by default and he just
admitted to being a terrible law whether
that meant does volume of lies or he's
very bad at them or in his case uniquely
probably both but what did you make of
that and should someone like him be
allowed to stay in congress I mean I
think that the voters are going to
decide whether he has to stay in
congress or not I don't have a lot of
standards for who gets kicked out of
Congress by members of their own party
because frankly I think that he's almost
the apotheosis of what politics is to
reach which is I'm gonna lie as much as
I can get away with it and then the
minute I can't get away with it I'll
just be like well I'm sorry I lied I
mean that's that's a high profile Jewish
man I want to play the clip where he
talks about being Jewish well he
separates the two parts of the word
let's have a look at this
I would always say I'm I was raised
Catholic but I come from a Jewish family
so that makes me Jewish I said it to a
room with a thousand people in November
people were hysterically laughing it was
funny to them they loved it
now the people that have already said
they were at that event and they weren't
laughing with him there's no sign that
of any evidence he has any Jewish
Heritage he claimed his grandparents
fled the Holocaust there seems to be no
evidence for that it's Barons are both
from Brazil and this idea that somehow
he can be Jewish I not actually Jewish
just ish well I mean honestly what he
should have said is I just on the inside
I feel Jewish I feel so Jewish on the
inside so I'm Jewish I mean what are you
going to do challenge my feelings but he
has repeatedly said he's Jewish I mean
not he wasn't joking we've seen the clip
so he said it repeatedly yeah no again I
sort of see him as sort of he's almost
the apex predator of politicians at this
point he's reached he's reached the
logical endpoint of where our politics
is going and you know it is the job of
people like you or me to call it out
when when he says things that are not
true but I think that we've we have
reached a sort of post-truth era not in
that people don't pay attention to the
truth but I'm not even sure how many
people care about the truth now I do
think that can be exaggerated I do think
the bulk of the population really does
care very much about the truth and
that's why I think that it there's going
to be a tidal wave of resentment that is
about to crash across how important is
the truth to you because you've got this
huge following that massive podcast tens
of millions of people watching your
stuff on social media so on how
important is truth to you now that
everything comes out of your mouth or
that you write is fact I mean it's it's
the most important thing to me because I
have to sleep at night I mean it's it's
something that I try to think about as
much as humanly possible is is never lie
to your audience never say to your
audience a thing that you know to be not
true and try to follow this the best
data possible and that does mean that
you're very often having to be more
nuanced than sort of the politics of the
situation may allow because the easiest
position in politics is always to take
the the hardest right or the hardest
left position the sort of most pure most
easily understood position or to just
play the easiest game of all which is
again my opponent is a bad guy my
opponent is a person who hates it when
we had our dust up at CNN about gun
control for example I'm not going to go
over all that again but had I been very
different with if I'd been very like
respectful and said look I'm a British
guy these aren't my laws I'm just as
horrified As You Are by these massacres
and didn't talk about gun control which
I think has always been a terribly
inflammatory phrase for many Americans
they don't want to be controlled and the
second I want to hear a British accent
telling them about how they should be
more control but if I phrased it as
about gun safety if that had always been
the debate in America how do you make it
safer in a country that has 400 million
firearms and circulation would that have
been a more constructive debate do you
think I think it would have been a more
informative debate and the reason being
I think that Clarity is is very much
opposed sometimes by by Passion we
listen we all get passionate about these
issues I'm not going to pretend I'm not
passionate on my show or I'm completely
dispassionate in all circumstances I'm
obviously not um but you know I think
that that would have allowed for the
kind of discussion where we could have
looked at data from various areas of the
world where where have regulations been
effective or have they not been
effective what are as I said on the show
actually at the time I believe what are
the risks and rewards of particular
policies that's where the good
discussion area I think gets done have
you been just found a point on the gun
thing but it and I'm aware many viewers
who watch this in America own guns and
support yeah I own guns the Second
Amendment rights and so on
where do you see the the line going as
you have all these massacres and as gun
ownership increa increases there's more
guns in circulation
what do you do about that I mean as a as
a country as big and powerful as America
what more can be done to just make it
safer I mean again the measures that
I've always suggested are measures that
tend more toward the gun owner than
toward the the weapon itself meaning
that we obviously need better screening
procedures for people who have a history
of severe mental illness we have to we
have red flag laws on the books but
they're not enacted I mean people people
don't actually practically follow the
red flag laws which is why I'm kind of
skeptical of the idea that if we pass
some more texts from the legislature
that's magically going to translate into
into better action what we need is more
alacrity from the cops I mean how many
of these mass shootings have we seen
where there are a thousand red flags and
the cops go to the house and then
they're told well no we're not we're not
going to do anything we're going to
leave you back out there it's almost in
every circumstance so we actually do
need law enforcement to have more
ability and will to carry out for
example when they know somebody is
severely mentally Disturbed or somebody
is shooting a gun at their mother which
we have we've had a case like that that
would be a time where you actually
remove the person's guns and and keep
track of them make sure they can't
actually get guns right I mean see if I
buy again when I was doing that debating
I would have had this kind of
conversation I can look back at those
and realize I was only my own emotions
over writing we all have this I mean
yeah it's interesting isn't it I do
think an important part of how we get to
a better place as as Society now away
from this tribalism away from all this
stuff is you've got to be prepared to
have this kind of conversation which
doesn't end up with me just looking at
you and shouting well you're a complete
idiot because you don't agree with me
right
um it's more complicated it's more
Nuance life is more Nuance than that I I
like to think so and I think that again
those conversations can be really really
productive I try to make a habit but I
have my regular Daily Show but I also
have a show called the Sunday special
that you've been on in which I bring on
a bunch of people who disagree from Bill
Maher to Anna kasparian and we actually
try to talk through these issues and um
I found a very surprisingly pleasant
experience yeah exactly